[Music]
you look sensational tell me about this
down Oh Oscar de la Renta
yes I got it yeah and Ian said he said
four times obviously it's the only way
to say I spent live in town um yeah I'm
I just want to like run away there's in
a few dresses that I want to do that too
and this is one of them might not make
it back yeah let's talk about someone
great because this movie is so so so
great we've all been through bad
breakups for sure not them talk to me
about a breakups it's funny now but in
the moment was not so funny Oh Oh
probably one of my favorites it was
about four weeks before I
I booked Jane and the break-up the guy
told me don't worry you'll find another
boyfriend you'll get a show oh yeah I
did was that to burn with that too much
shade that was the funniest one and I
loved it and I loved every moment I was
like oh thank you for predicting my
amazing future I appreciate you know who
you are what is your advice that you
give to friends when they're going
through a breakup time do time and like
it's a advice because nobody wants to
wait nobody wants time to pass nobody
wants that and I don't want that I know
this but it really is the cure-all
because nothing could make it go away
like besides time there is one scene
that everyone's gonna be talking about
when you are in the bodega singing
Salinas dreaming of you
[Music]
talk to me about what it was like
filming that scene how much fun was that
of the greatest thing ever and my
favorite was they're like do you want us
to send you this song so you can
memorize it and I was like really do you
think I need to memorize that song
I mean Selena like a Grabbe Selena
recipes love that that woman changed so
many lives and so to be able to sing
that song that bodega was really dope to
have the clearance of that we were like
sweating it we're like ladies please I
get Claire voice well I was gonna say
Selena's family is currently working on
a Netflix show about her life you are in
the Netflix family your producer
yourself you're an actress could we see
you be a part of this I'm gonna support
it I mean it's big it's happening so I'm
not gonna take it
I don't know I'm very excited cuz I just
read about the announcement the other
day and I can't wait to watch it
oh I can't wait to watch it yeah it's
gonna be amazing
you've already found your someone great
you brought Joe with you tonight and
he's in it he's in remember him think
about the scene where look Ethan me or
meeting in the flashback that's Joe the
whole same fire my man is in this movie
yo give me that wedding update I know
you've got something for we're probably
gonna run away after the show you've
been telling us you're gonna elope for a
while what are three things that you
know that you're gonna have at your
wedding pizza hopefully Joe and and
what else do I wanted my wedding my
family that's about it lastly a girl no
you're not you're a fabulous and amazing
and I love you so much but lastly you're
filming the Jane the virgin finale when
you read that script what was your
initial reaction how's it going you know
they recorded it they recorded and I
don't know if they're ever gonna release
it but Wow
it was a mess we were all bawling but
I'm shooting it now I shot this morning
a shot last night and I still like four
more days left and to be honest I like I
think it's gonna really get to me one
it's supposed to tie it's time to go
back and we won't be going back so I
feel like August will be hard but like
right now I'm like I'll see them all of
it see them soon
[Music]